la carte scolaire pour la rentrée 2013
se dessine le département se dote de 74
postes supplémentaires dans le premier
degré maternelle et primaire et les
yvelines voit le nombre des élèves
progresser avec une hausse attendue de
800 écoliers 66 ouvertures de classes
sont envisagées dans le département sur
notre secteur à bois d'arcy coignières
elancourt guyancourt la verrière
maurepas montigny le bretonneux plaisir
saint cyr l'école et trappe a contrario
dans le projet de carte scolaire
dévoilée par l'inspection académique
quarante neuf fermetures de classes sont
envisagées à elancourt guyancourt les
clayes-sous-bois magny les hameaux
maurepas montigny le bretonneux trappe
et voisins le bretonneux
d'autre part un accueil spécifique de
nouveaux élèves de moins de 3 ans est
prévu dans 11 écoles dont à maurepas et
trois écoles concernées à trappes
ces mesures seront soumises à l'avis du
conseil départemental de l'éducation
nationale qui se réunira à la mi avril